[موسيقى]
من العربيه احييكم انا ريما مكتبي وهذه
نشره الخمسه نبداها بابرز العناوين
من العراق
انا بتحمل
كل المسؤوليه
اما تم في 30 يونيو
اول مره بشهادته علنا امام القضاء ويقر
بمسؤوليته عن انقلاب عام 89
[موسيقى]
المنتخب الارجنتيني يحظى باستقبال الابطال
في بوني ستارز بعد فوزه بكاس العالم
شدد رئيس الروسي على ان بلاده تشهد تحديات
كبيره وصعبه تمس سيادتها مؤكدا على ضروره
جديده في اوكرانيا
لذلك روسيا ممتنه لكل الجنود والضباط
الذين اظهروا شجاعه استثنائيه للدفاع عن
وطنهم وادائي واجبهم العسكري في العمليه
الخاصه تلك الواجب سيساعد في اقامه حياه
طبيعيه وسليمه للمواطنين في المناطق
الجديده من روسيا
ووصف بوتين الوضع في مناطق دوناتس
ونوجزنك لوجان
بالوضع صعب للغايه واضاف ان لدى روسيا
حاليا قدره كافيه لخلق تهديدا لاوكرانيا
والقيام باعمال تكتيكيه من بيلاروسيا
الواقعه على الحدود الشماليه
لكن الناس الذين يعيشون الامل عليكم
لحمايتهم ومن واجبكم ان تفعل
سلامتهم واحترام حقوقهم وحرياتهم قدر
الامكان من جديد
القوات بالاليات العسكريه والاسلحه
الحديثه
حاليا في الجهه الغربيه
235 قذيفه وصاروخا من اثنين و 50 موقعا في
الساعات الاخيره
من جهه اخرى اكد مراسل العربيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه ارسلت وحدات عسكريه الى
سوليدار
حيث لا تزالوا المعارك دائره لسيطره على
المدينه
العربيه حذيفه عدل اهلا بك حذيفه ما هي
المستجدات الميدانيه اقل له
تحياتي ريما يعني ادعي لي ابدا بوضع
الكهرباء في المدن المختلفه طبعا ال
الضربه الاخيره اثرت بشكل كبير على محطات
الكهرباء وفي العاصمه كيف عادت الى عدد
كبير من الاحياء ولكن هنالك احياء لليوم
الثاني على التوالي لم يعد التيار
الكهربائي وتعالي ايضا من انقطاع في
التدفئه وفي المياه هذا الامر ينطبق كذلك
على عدد من
المدنسه همم بلطف وعدد من المدن خاصه
المدن الشرقيه ايضا سومي تعاني ايضا
الجزئيا من انقطاع في الكهرباء والمياه
والتدفئه اما في الوضع الميداني للحرب
طبعا الخبرز اليوم هو زياره الرئيس زينكي
الى جبهه حيث زار الرئيس الجنود وقدم لهم
جوائز الدوله وقدم لهم الميداليات واطلع
على الاوضاع في الجبهه وشكره الجلود طبعا
على القتال في هذه الجبهه وهي الجبهه
الاشرس والاعنف في الصراع الروسي
الاوكراني في الوقت الحالي طبعا جبهه
عريضه جدا تمتد من هو النفقه انت منطقه
سوليدار همم القوات الروسيه شلت حوالي همم
هجوم في حوالي 20 بلده متزامن اطلقت اربعه
صواريخ في اتجاه اماكن تمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه قامت بتنفيذ 50 ضربه صاروخيه
من
انظمه همم انظمه الصواريخ المتعدده في
الجبهات المختلفه في دونيسك ايضا الوضع في
لوغاز يحتدم قال حاكم مقاطعه لوكاس قال ان
الوضع همم يعني يتحسن بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه هنالك تقدم بطيء قال اننا
نبتعد عده كيلومترات من همم من همم منطقه
همم طبعا الان الصراع يدور حول مدينتين
صغيرتين تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه الوصول
اليها ولكن قال ان المسافه ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه وما بين هاتين المدينه مزروعه
بعدد كبير جدا من الالغام وهذا ما يعطي
تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه في راح الاتجاه
ولكن انه قال انه مطمئن على انهم سيصلون
الى هاتين المدينتين قري- قريبا حذيفه كيف
تلقفت اوكرانيا لقاء الروس وبيلاروسيا
ويعني اقر رئيس روسي بلحظات صعبه في هذه
الحرب بالنسبه لروسيا والمناطق الخاضعه
لسيطرتها ولكن يبدو ان هناك استعدادات
لخطوات تكتيكيه في الحرب هل من مخاوف داخل
اوكرانيا
العسكريه اكثر من مره وتحدث عنها الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديميرسيليسك طبعا
الاستخبارات العسكريه قالت انه في الوقت
الحالي لا يوجد مؤشر لعمليه هجوم من
الاراضي الروسيه ولكنها على الرغم من ذلك
تقول انه هذا لا يمنع انه قد يكون ذلك عمل
تكتيكي لعمليه يحمل الاراضي الخطوات
العمليه التي قامت بها
قامت بها وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه اولا هي
بدات في انشاء حائط همم يفصل الحدود
الروسيه الحدود الاوكرانيه الفيلا الروسيه
وقامت خلف هذا الجدار قام بحفر الخنادق
وقامت بايضا انشاء جداول للمياه وكل ذلك
لمنع اي تقدم من الاراضي الفروسيه ولكن
على اهم انها ارسلت عدد كبير من القوات في
الحدود الروسيه بلا الروسيه الاوكرانيه هي
ترابه الموقع وكذلك طبعا على طول الشريط
الحدود مع فلسطين شكرا جزيلا لكيف كان
معنا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عدل
ومن الجهه الروسيه وبحث التطورات وتصريحات
رئيس الروسيه ينضم الينا من موسكو المحلل
السياسي رائد جبر رائد اهلا بك يقر بوتين
بصعوبات في المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره روسيا
التقى الهمم بيلاروس ولكن والاعلام الغربي
يتخوف من خطوات تكتيكيه او دخول بيلاروسيا
نوعا ما الى هذه الحرب ماذا يعني كلام
بوتن اليوم يقر بصعوبات
يعني
الفعاليه التي كان يتحدث
امام الجنود والضباط الذين شاركوا في
المعارك في المناطق الجنوب الشرق افريقيا
لذلك من الطبيعي ان يتحدث امام عن لحظات
صعبه الوضع همم صعبوا هذا الامر لهم
اعينهم وهم عائدون للتو من الجبهه لذلك لم
يكن بمقدور بودر ان يتحدث يعني عن تقدم
واسع وعن معركه سهله همم امام هؤلاء
الجنود ضد الظاهرات عموما كل الفعاليات
التي يقيمها الكريم في في الاونه الاخيره
هي تهدف الى رفع الروح
الى التاكيد بانه هناك صعوبات
بالفعلواجهها في ارض المعركه ولكن النصر
سيكون حديث روسيا كما قال بوتن اليوم قال
مررنا بلحظات صعبه مثل هذه في التاريخ
ودائما انتصرت روسيا الان علينا ان ننتصر
من اجل نحافظ على استقلال وسياده البلاد
اذا هو كان يعني يحاول رفع الروح المعنويه
لهؤلاء الضباط والجنود ولمن يسمعوا اصلا
من يعني بقيه
الوحدات العسكريه وما الى ذلك والحديث في
نفس الوقت
عن وسائل الاعلام الغربيه ليست
دقيق لبوت هذه العبارات ان هناك تظليل
اعلامي وهناك تضخيم لخسائر في مقابل طبعا
وروسيا ولكن نفس الوقت مجريات الامور على
الارض تتحدث عن نفسها كنا يعني بعد شهرين
نقترب من عام على هذه الحرب وكان على اساس
انه روسيا بتاخذ اوكرانيا خلال اسابيع
اليوم مازلنا بنفس المعارك الدائره كيف
يمكن ان نقيم اللقاء بين روسيا وبين روسيا
امس
يعني اعتقد ان اللقاء لضبط الساعات لاعاده
ضبط الساعات بلاروسيا هي الحليف الاوساق
والاقرب الى موسكو هناك بالفعل نشاط عسكري
مشترك يعني الحديث عن انخراط بلا روسيا
بشكل مباشر في المعركه الان هناك سجالات
كثيره بجانب تكهنات اعتقد انه هناك
تحضيرات الانشن عمليه من الاراضي الروسيه
انا يعني اتفق تماما مع التقييمات القياده
الاوكرانيه في هذا الشهر ولكن همم علينا
ان نذكر اصلا
يعني هناك همم قوات روسيه انطلقت من
الاراضي البيلاروسيه هناك طائرات تمتلك من
هناك معسكرات تدريب على اراضي بيلاروسيا
للقوات الروسيه والقوات الجديده التي تذهب
الى المعركه يعني هناك انخراط من نوع ما
اعتقد انه اهميه هذه الزياره وهذه
الاتفاقات التي وردت اخيرا اولا هناك حديث
عن نظام دفاعي مشترك اذا هذا يعني تعزيز
القدرات العسكريه الروسيه المباشره على
اراضي بيلاروسيا من اجل يعني مواجهه اي
تحديات مشتركه كما يقول الترفان همم هذه
مرحله جديده في العلاقات
يعني هو توسيع رقعه الاشتباك او تغيير
قواعد الاشتباك
تهيئه الامور في حال اضطر البلد عن يعني
روسيا وبالروسيا الى توسيع رقعه الاشتراك
لان يكون هناك ارضيه يعني عسكريه جاهزه
لهذا الموضوع لا اعتقد انه المعركه تتسع
الان ولكن تهيئه الظروف من المهمه بالنسبه
للطرفين القيام بذلك خصوصا على خلفيه انه
زاد من وجوده في بولندا وفي عدد
خصوصا لذلك في المقابل
موسكومان بنفس الخطوه يعني نشر الوحدات
عسكريه مشتركه اضافيه اقامه مظله الدفاع
جويريه مشتركه وما الى ذلك شكرا
نقلت نيو تايمز ان الولايات المتحده كان
لديها فريق في اوكرانيا يضم نحو 40 فردا
تابعينا لقوه المهمه الوطنيه السيبريانيه
لمساعدتك في تعزيز دفاعاتها لكنها قالت ان
ذلك كان قبل انسحاب جميع القوات الامريكيه
من اوكرانيا قبل بدء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه مضيفه انا واشنطن وصلت القيام
بعمليات من داخل الولايات المتحده لمساعده
اوكرانيا على وقف المتسللين سيبرانيين
الروس
لاول مره منذ حرب الجواسيس بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق والولايات المتحده اثناء
الحرب البارده تشتعل حرب اخرى صامته
ميدانها الفضاء سبراني بين موسكو ووشن
صحيفه نيويورك
قوه المهمه
2012 كجزء من القياده السبرانيه الامريكيه
وهي المنظمه العسكريه في الولايات المتحده
القوه بدورها تدعم الدفاع الرقمي
الاوكراني عبر مشاورات يوميه ما ساعد في
الكشف عن الالاف من الاشارات التحذيريه
لشبكات الكمبيوتر الاوكرانيه التي يحتمل
ان تكون معارضه للخطر بحسب الصحيفه وحتى
الان يبدو الامر انه قد تم ردوا روسي عن
توجيه هجمه سوبرانيه مباشره ضد الولايات
المتحده او حلف الناتو هذا ما يقوله قائد
القوه السبرانيه الامريكيه الذي يتحسب من
هجمات تستهدف الولايات المتحده ربما
ينفذها ناشطون سبراميون روس يفلتون من
سلطه الكرملين الذي لم يدرس بعد قرار
مهاجمه الناتو وفقا لنيويورك تايمز
المخاوف الامريكيه دفعت واشنطن الى تخصيص
2000 شخص من عناصر القوات المسلحه للعمل
ضمن القوه السبرانيه التي وزعت ايضا
ثمانيه وثلاثين فريقا في 21 دوله للمساعده
على تعزيز الشبكات الحاسوبيه من استهداف
انظمه معلوماتها وبيانات المؤسسات
الحكوميه لمسح او تعطيل او تدمير خدمتها
في حرب تحقق مصالح بلدانها من غير الحاجه
لمعدات ثقيله وبتكلفه اقل من استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه حنان المصري العربيه
وتتابعونا ولكن بعد فصل
العمله الايرانيه تهوي مجددا بسبب
الاحتجاجات وازمه الاتفاق النووي
اهلا بكم من جديد يعقدوا في الاردن مؤتمر
بغداد للتعاون والشراكه في دورته الثانيه
بمشاركه عربيه ودوليه المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه العراقيه احمد الصحاف قال ان
المؤتمر يهدي فون تاكيد على دعم دول
المشاركه للعراق في عده ملفات ابرزها
سياده العراق
واستقراره ودعم العمليه السياسيه والمسيره
الاقتصاديه والتنميه واعاده الاعمار ويحضر
المؤتمر الدول التي شاركت في الدوره
الاولى بالاضافه الى كل من سلطنه عمان
ومملكه البحرين والاتحاد الاوروبي فيما تم
الدعوه سفراء الدول العربيه ودول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجموعه العشرين والاعضاء
الدائمين في مجلس الامن
قال رئيس مجلس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
سوداني وخلال كلمه القاها في مؤتمر قمه
بغداد الثاني قال ان المؤتمر يعكس رغبه
بغداد في ارساء وتعزيز الشراكه الاقليميه
والدوليه السوداني تعهد بان لا يسمح
باستخدام اراضي العراق لانطلاق اي تهديد
لدول الجوار قائلا الى العراق بنفسه عن
سياسات المحاور ودعوات التصعيد داعيا
تركيا وايران الى ضمانه امن العراق المائي
نحو تعزيز مسيره العلاقات بين دولنا في
مختلف المجالات
وتطوير وتطيرتها بالشكل الذي يسلم في
تحقيق وارسائي قواعد الاستقرار
والرخاء والتنميه في المنطقه
ويفتح المجال واسعا امام سبل الحوار
والنقاش
لتبادل الاراء
وتعميق المفاهيم
ان فكره تاسيس مؤتمر بغداد
الجغرافي والاقليمي اضافه الى الدول
الصديقه
تتبنى حكومتنا نهجا منفتحا يهدف لبناء
شركات اقليميه ودوليه مبنيه على المصالح
المشتركه بما في ذلك ان شاء الله
استراتيجيه التكامليه لربط العراق مع
محيطه الاقليمي
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اكد خلال كلمته في مؤتمر بغداد 2
وقوف سعوديه جنبنا الى جنب مع العراق لصون
استقراره وحفظه سيادته ودعم جهودي
التنمويه ونهوض به لمرحله جديده تقدم
المصلحه الوطنيه على اي اعتبارات اخرى
مع العراق
والمعرفه والنهوض به الى مرحله جديده
تقدموا مصلحه الوطنيه فيها على اي
اعتبارات اخرى اصحاب الجلاله السمو
المعالي من اجتماعنا اليوم يؤكدونا رغبه
المشتركه والصادقه لدولنا الاستمرار وتيره
التعاون والدعم لجمهوريه العراق
وترجمتها الى شركات فعليه تحقق نتائج
العراق الاقتصاديه والتنمويه
ورخائها
يرتباطا
ورخاء جيرانها ومنطقها
العاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني اكد
في كلمته على ان المنطقه بحاجه الى
الاستقرار والسلام العادل والشامل مشيرا
الى ان العراق ركن اساسي في امن المنطقه
للتاكيد على الدور المحوري للعراق بنسبه
للمنطقه
ودوره في تقريب وجهات النظر لتعزيز
التعاون الاقليمي
يعني عقده اجتماعنا اليوم في وقت تواجهوا
فيه المنطقه
الازمات الامنيه والسياسيه بالاضافه الى
تحدي تحدي تحديات
تحدياتي للابن الغذائي والمائي والصحي
وضروتي تامين
امداداتي الطاقه و سلاسل
التوريد والتعامل مع تداعيات التغير
المناخي
وخلال كلمته في مؤتمر بغداد جدد الرئيس
الفرنسي اما نويل دعم بلاده للعراق منجدا
بتاثيرات الخارجيه التي يتعرض لها وداعيا
في الوقت نفسه الدول المشاركه في القمه
الى المساعده في تعزيز امن العراق
والمنطقه
وامنه وسيادته
العراق اليوم بيت مسرح مصر تاثيرات
وانتهاكات وزعزعه استقرار تؤثر على
المنطقه
هذا المؤتمر بهذه تشكيله لكي تجتمع في
قاعه واحده كل الدول والامم التي يمكنها
ان تساهم في تعزيز السياده العراق
وبالتالي استقراره
ينضم الينا من البحر الميت مراسل العربيه
عمار الهندي عمار اهلا بك التصريحات
العلنيه واضحه سمعناها كلها ولكن بهكذا
مؤتمرات من المهمه يجري خلف الكواليس هل
من لقاءات الجانبيه ثنائيه ثلاثيه ما
نلتقي من وماذا جرى خلف الكواليس
الافتتاحيه والكلمات المعلنه التي كانت
مفتوحه للاعلام جرت مباحثات سريعه
ومشاورات في داخل القاعه كانت مغلقه
للاعلام والان ونحن نتحدث اليك تجرى هذه
اللقاءات الثنائيه مع علمناه بان العاهل
الاردني التقى ولكن انا اعلم ان الجميع
يعني ينتظر ما اذا كانت هنالك لقاءات
جانبيه على سبيل المثال همم مهمه على سبيل
المثال لقاء وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان ووزير الخارجيه الايراني
حتى هذه اللحظه لا تاكيدات ما اذا كانت
فعلا عقدت هذه المباحثات الجانبيه همم في
همم بعد ان انتهت الجلسه المغلقه للاعلام
بعد قليل ايضا ريما هنالك مؤتمر الصحافي
سيكون ثلاثي سيجمع وزير الخارجيه الاردني
ووزير الخارجيه العراقي ووزير الخارجيه
الفرنسي لتلخيص لاهم ما جاء في هذه
الجلسات المغلقه وهذه المشاورات المغلقه
الجميع طبعا ينظر كما تحدثت الجلسه يعني
كلمات كانت معلنه وواضحه ولكن ما وراءها
كان كثيرا والحديث الذي تركز على نعم
همم يعني بالموضوع اللقاءات مع الايراني
اي همم مسؤول عربي او غربي يلتقي الجانب
الايراني مهم في هذه اللحظات لانه فرنسا
موجوده الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون هل
هذا المؤتمر فقط على موضوع العراق ام ايضا
يعني دور ايران في المنطقه مثلا
التاثيرات لانه في تعهدات من قبل رئيس
الوزراء العراقي ان لا يسمح لاي احد ان
يستخدم اراضيه لتهديد امن واستقرار اي بلد
في الجوار
بكل تاكيد اللقاءات الجانبيه مع ال مع
وزير الخارجيه الايراني مطروحه ويعني مهمه
من الجميع لانه اكثر من ملف يعني الاردن
مثلا لديه قلق فيما يتعلق بالحدود مع
سوريا والدعم الايراني للمليشيات فربما
تكون هنالك لقاءات جانبيه ومباحثات جانبيه
معه ايضا جزء بورن لديه يعني متابعه للملف
النووي الايراني ايضا همم الملفات الاخرى
كلها تتعلق في الجنه لانه اذا ما نظرنا
الى المساله ريما من من الخارج فهي نعم
تتعلق بالعراق ولكن صلب الموضوع هو ايضا
تدخلات الخارجيه التي لم ترد صراحه على
الكلمات على اللسان احد بانها المقصود
منها ايران ولكن الجميع يعلم بانها هنالك
يعني دوله اسمها ايرانيه الاكثر تدخل في
العراق وبالتالي كل المصالح على العراقيه
وكل الخطط العراقيه وحتى المشاريع التي
تتحدث عنها العاهل الاردني وتحدث عنها
الرئيس السيسي عبد الفتاح السيسي الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي كلها هنالك من
يتهم بايران بعرقتها لانه هنالك حجر عتره
يعتبره البعض اسمه ايراني ايراني يقف امام
اتطور علاقات العراق الحديث مع جيرانه
وتنمويه واقتصاديا ايضا هنالك مساله
المياه العراقيه ومخاطبه ورئيس الوزراء
العراقي بايران وتركيا بضروره اعطاء حصتها
كامله
احياء الاتفاق النووي لم يكن مفاجئا لنا
عائدا يعني بعيد انا عرف طهران مقترح
احياء هذا الاتفاق لم يكن همم
مفاجئا وايضا طهران حطمت كل امال العوده
للاتفاق النووي همم سنتابع معك خلال ان
اشارات عمار لنعرف ايضا مخرجات هذا
المؤتمر وما هي النتائج سيكون يوم طويل
يعطيك الف عافيه انت وفريق العمل كان معي
مراسل العربيه عمار الهندي من البحر الميت
الى ملابس السودان في اول شهاده واستجواب
على نيل الرئيس السوداني المخلوع عمر
البشير امام القضاء السوداني منذ سقوط
نظامه قبل البشير بكلمه امام المحكمه
استمرت لاكثر من ساعه ابرز كلام البشير
امام المحكمه اليوم كان اعلانه كامل
المسؤوليه عن انقلاب 30 مليون يورو عام
وتبريئاته للحركه الاسلاميه اي الفرع
السوداني لجماعه الاخوان كما انه استغل
الفرصه العلنيه لتعديد انجازاته السياسيه
والخدميه طوال ثلاثه عقود كان فيها على
سده الحكم في السودان
لكن عايز اثبت حقيقه مولانا
انه كله اخواننا اعضاء مجلس الثوره
الموجودين هنا
في هذه القاعه
ما كان عندهم اي دور
في التخطيط او التنفيذ
وانما تم اختياره كوكب من غير الضباط
القوات المسلحه عشان يمثل
بعض الجهال واؤكد ايضا
انه ما في اي مدينه دخل معنا
عامل عسكري بحث
ت اعترافاته خلال اجتماعات سريه كانت
بثتها قناه العربيه حصريا
2019 كشف وثائقي الاسرار الكبرى جماعه
الاخوان الاجتماع
العربيه والحدث
كشفت عن اسرار التنظيم الذي حكم السودان
قرابه 30 عاما وكواليس انقلاب عام
1989 قضيه تعود للواجهه بعد افاده قضائيه
للبشير هي الاولى
عسكريه لم تشارك فيه اي شخصيه مدنيه او اي
عضو في مجلس قياده الثوره
واعلم انه الاعتراف هو سيد الادله
اعترافات تتضارب مع تصريحات سابقه للبشير
في اجتماعات الشورى لما يعرف بالحركه
الاسلاميه تحدث فيها صراحه عن الدور
الكبير الذي منيح لجماعه الاخوان في
السودان ودورهم في انقلاب 89
عن اهميه تسلم جماعه الاخوان للسلطه
بالطريقه التي يقررونها احنا يا شيخ حسن
هنعدي اللون اللي حكيت الحركه الاسلاميه
لانك انت جبته في اجتماع احنا ضبان وبتاع
اخواته وقرروا
وثائقي الاسرار الكبرى جماعه الاخوان كان
اعترافات بالصوت والصوره ليست للبشير فقط
بل قاده ينتمون للاخوان بزعامه حسن
الترابي وعلي عثمان طه النائب السابق
للرئيس المعزول الذي قاد فعليا المجموعه
المدنيه المسلحه ووضع اللمسات الاخيره
الانقلابه
انه يشاركني زياده معظم يا اخواننا ان لم
يكن جميعهم في الجنه مع انه بالمعطيات
التي كانت
89 لو عاد التاريخ القهطره
فازلينقف نفس الموقف وسنقوم بالتغيير الذي
حدث
اقرار وعلى عثمان طه علانيه يرمز الى ان
جماعه الاخوان كانت الحاكم المتحكمه وان
حزب المؤتمر الوطني يمثل فقط واجهه
للاخوان يتحكمون من خلالها علنا في الدوله
ومواردها
الفرح الان هي دوله المشروعه الاسلاميه
التي يجب المحافظه عليها وان تكون خياران
وجهتنا منصبا للمحافظه عليها للمفارقه
كواليس حصريه للعربيه والحدث تعود لاعوام
تؤكد اليوم النظام المعزول وهو ناقد نفسه
باعترافات لا اسس لها تتزامل مع ذكرى
الرابعه للثوره التاسعه عشر من ديسمبر عام
2018 التي اطاحت بالمشي
عبد العظيم اهلا بيك
اول مره نرى متهم اا في محكمه يقف بهذه
الطريقه ولا يدلي بافاده ادلى بمؤتمر صحفي
واا يعني على همم او نوع من البيان
السياسي او الحمل السياسيه لماذا سمح
القاضي بهذا لماذا اعطي عمر بشير هذا
المنبر
نعم اهلا وسهلا هو الاب من الواضح جدا ان
القاضي ااا يريد ان يعطي المتهم الفرصه
كامله متهم كان رئيس جمهوريه وهكذا يريد
ان يعطيه الفرصه كامله حتى
يستخرج منه كثير من الاعترافات واعتقد ان
القاضي نجح بشكل كبير في ان يستدرجوا لهذه
الخطبه او كانت ضده لم تكن في صالحه والان
الشارع السوداني ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بدات في تفنيد ما كان ما قاله البشير في
المحكمه بعد ثلاث سنوات او اربع سنوات
وكان لا يريد ان يتحدث فهذه الخطبه الان
لم تكون في صالح من الواضح ان حتى القنوات
الفضائيه وما نديره الان هو ضد البشير لان
كان يتناغب بشكل كبير وكان شديدارت في
المحكمه في اول الامر قال انه لم هذه
الاقوال ليست اقواله ثم رفع يده للقاضي
وقال ان هذه الاقوال الاقوال وبدا مرتبكا
بدا يتحدث بشكل كثيف جدا عن ما انجز خلال
ال- ال- ال- السنوات حكمه وكلها تناقضات
التناقض الاكبر كان في ان هؤلاء المدنيين
لم يكن لديهم دور في الانقلاب وهو
الانقلاب عسكري بالكامل لان احنا لم نكون
نحتاج لمدنين نعم هو انقلاب عسكري بالكامل
واعتقد ان ما عرضته الان من اسرار قناه
العربيه والحدث الاسرار الكبرى الى
اخواننا المسلمين اجابه على هذا الارتباك
وهذا التناقض وهي تنصب في انها ضد البشير
او ضد الحركه الاسلاميه نفسها التي ارخت
العنان للبشير الذي جاءت به كما قال دكتور
الترابي والشعب السوداني يحفظ عباره
لدكتور حسن الترابي هو عراب الحركه
الاسلاميه وقتها بانه قال له اذهب الى
القصر رئيسا وساذهب الى السجن حديثا هذه
عباره في اذيات السياسه متداوله وايضا
الترابي لديه قول شهير كان في جامعه
القران الكريم بعد ان
تمزيق الدستور من الدستور الذي كتبه
الاخوان انفسهم قاموا بتمزيقه وتم طرد حسن
الترابي من المجلس الوطني وقتها وقال في
جامعه القران الكريم انهم كانوا يحكمون من
وراء حجاب هم الذين كانوا يديروا المشهد
حتى العسكريين كانواجهه فقط لانهم كان
يستغفر الله
همم
الاسلام السياسي وحركه الاخوان المسلمين
يمكن ايضا قراءه هذا البيان المؤتمر
الصحفي كما قال اليوم البعض الجميع تفاجا
برؤيه عمر البشير بهذا الشكل اليوم يمكن
ايضا قراءه الموضوع على انه همم بس الروح
بالحركه السياسيه همم وبمناصره صحيح انه
يحاكم لكن هناك تيار شعبي يخلف عمر البشير
هل ممكن ان نرى تحرك سياسي اكبر لحلفاء
وان وبعد هذا الكلام
نعم هو حاول ان يفعل ذلك حاول ان يظهر
بمظهر الرجل السوداني الشجاع الذي يتحمل
المسؤوليات ويفدي اا اصحابه ويفدي زملائه
بانه يتحمل كامل المسؤوليه وكان هنالك
عسكريين من قبل هاشم العطا وغيره تحملوا
هذه تحملوا تبعيات الانقلاب بانفسهم وتم
تقديمهم للمشانق وهكذا وهو طبعا رجل عمره
الان تجاوز السبعين سنه يغارب التنانين
سنه فيعلم انه لن يقدم للاعدام او يحاكم
يحاكم غليظ وهو ادين من قبل وتم وضعه في
اصلاحيه ولم يوضع في السجن بغلاظه كما كان
متوقع كل ذلك هذه حسابات البشير وحسابات
المحامين الذين في المحكمه ايضا شهد الناس
كيف ان المحامي جاء اليه وطلب منه ان يقول
هذا الكلام ولكن اعتقد انه الان انصار
واقعه في في مشكله اكبر في هذا الحديث هو
همم اوضح كيف كانت الحركه تقوم بالاكاذيب
همم الان الشعب السوداني يرى ان حركه
الاخوان لمين ظهر لك تجذب منذ 89 كذب في
الاول الدكتوره الترابي بان قلت له اصاب
الى القصر رئيسا وهو اليوم يكذب ايضا
ويقول انه تبنى هذا الانجلاب وهل فعله دون
المدنيين كلها قامت على اكاذيب الحركه
الاسلاميه منذ 89 بدات تحكم السودان
بالخداع شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم الكاتب
الصحفي شوقي عبد العظيم
نعود الى مؤتمر صحفي في ختام مؤتمر بغداد
تاريخيا همم عظيما على الارهاب بتضحيات
كبيره همم هذا النصر هو النصر لنا جميعا
لان الارهاب هو عدوا لنا جميعا فالوقوف
الى جانب العراق في جهوده المستمر مكافحه
الارهاب وموقف مبدئي للمملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه والجميع الدول التي شاركتها
اشكركم مره اخرى اعطيها الكلام الان رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه العراق الشقيقه
وبعدها تتحدث زميلاتنا وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه فاقد هذا الكلام التي تفضل
شكرا جزيلا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء الخير
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اعوذ بدايه ان اشكر المملكه ملكا وحكومه
وشعبان
للاستغفار هذا المؤتمر وايضا اريد ان اشكر
الحكومه الفرنسيه والرئيس ماكرون اللي
دعمه لعقد هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر بغداد نسخه
ثانيه
حينما نتحدث عن مؤتمر بغداد يعني ان
الامور تتجه ودعم بغداد ودعم العراق هذا
المؤتمر كما كان النسخه الاولى مؤتمر
بغداد
الاول اا هو من اجل الاستمرار دعم العراق
ولكن هذا المؤتمر ايضا
نظل حواريه بين الدول دول جوار العراقي
دول الجوار العراقي ودول الخليجيه
طبعا حضور مجموعه من ممثلين دول الاخرى
بالاضافه الى ممثلين المنظمات الدوليه
تحدث ايضا عن مظله للتعاون والعمل المشترك
اذا
مؤتمر بغداد ليس فقط لدعم العراق وانما
ايضا
للعمل المشترك في المحيط الاقليمي
والمحيط الدولي التحديد التحديات اللي
نواجهها جميعا
تحديات اللي تواجهها
الحكومه العراقيه تحديات
اكثرها اقليميه ودوليه يعني حينما نتحدث
عن
تحديات البيئيه المناخير حينما نتحدث عن
تحديات الامنيه حينما نتحدث عن تحديات
الاقتصاديه في الوقت الحاضر التضخم حينما
نتحدث عن تحيد تحديات طاقه
حتى الامن الغذائي الامن الدوائي
وهذه تحديات جميعها تحتاج الى عمل مشترك
تحتاج الى موقف مشترك ومن هنا انطلق مؤتمر
بغداد للعمل المشترك لمواجهه مجموعه من
التحديات التي تواجه هذه البلدان في
المنطقه
اكتفي بهذا القدر من المؤتمر الصحفي تحدث
فيه وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن الصفدي
ونظيره فؤاد حسين وايضا في هذه الاثناء
يرد خبر عاجل من كل الكرملين فقد حدد
بوتين غدا موعد لاطلاق الخطط العسكريه
لروسي عام 2023
وايضا يعني بعد شهرين تقريبا سيصادف مرور
عام على حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا نتبع في
شان الايراني فقد هوت العمله الايرانيه
الى مستوى منخفض جدا مع استمرار
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه الشعبيه من جهه
وغياب اي مؤشر بشان تسويه الملف النووي
الايراني من جهه اخرى وتشيل التقارير الى
ان سعر الدولار في السوق الايرانيه الحره
ارتفع مره اخرى حيث تم تداوله عند الساعه
39,760 طنط
[موسيقى]
وتتابعونا في الخامسه
دراسه طبيه تتوقعوا مليون وفاه في الصين
بسبب كرونا بعد رفع قيود احتواء الفيروس
اهلا بكم من جديد استقبل الالاف من
المشجعين المبتهجين منتخب الارجنتين
استقبال الابطال في بوني ستارز في الساعات
الاولى من فجر اليوم بعد وصول الطائره
التي اقرت ليونيل ميسي ورفاقه عقب الفوز
بكاس العالم لكره القدم
هذه لقطات مباشره من بويسايرس وهذه
المشاهد مكرره من ليله
المباراه النهائيه بين الارجنتين وفرنسا
ونرى المنتخب الارجنتين يخترق الحشود
علمتني حافله باص مكشوفه ويعني يقومون
بتحيه
للجماهير الذين كانوا بانتظار هذا الفوز
التاريخي
للارجنتين كانت مباريات مهمه جدا من اجمل
المباريات في
المونديالات السابقه بين فرنسا والارجنتين
الفريقين لاعبه بطريقه مميزه جدا لدرجه ان
الحسن كان ضربات الترجيحيه كانت فعلا
مباريات مميزه هذا المشهد همم يتكرر من
ليلتين او ثلاثه اعتقد يوم المونديال كان
بيتمش ديسمبر
هذه الساحه في بونس ايرس مقتده بالحشود
وبشاق كره القدم وتحديدا المنتخب
الارجنتيني
ليونيل ميسي كان نجم هذه المباريات وكان
هناك الكثير من الجدل على او حول ابقاء
رونالدو على هامش هذه
الجيم او اللعبه
ويعني الكثير من
تحليلات ستاتي في الايام المقبله ولكن
الفوز هو الفوز وطبعا كان حاضر الرئيس
الفرنسي اما نوال مكروه المباراه بشكل
شخصي ليؤيد فريقه الفرنسي الذي لعب بشكل
جيد جدا ايضا
اذا نحن حافله تقلوا المنتخب الارجنتيني
تخترق الحصود في وسط بوليس ايرس هذه
اللقطات لميسي
اذا كانت الصوره واضحه فعلا ميسي وهو كان
نجم هذا الفريق رغم انه الجميع لاعبه
بطريقه محترفه جدا
وكذبوا
كاس عن جداره
الاف الحشود متواجده
نعيش طبيعات الممزال الذي كان مميز جدا
يعني حتى المغرب البلد همم ايضا فريق
المغرب يصل اليوم همم الى بلاد ايه وهناك
احتفالات كبيره لاستقبال
ايضا دور تاريخي قام به المنتخب المغربي
في هذا المونديال
[موسيقى]
الفوز الجميل
دي المنتخب الارجنتيني على الانتصارات
جميله دائما وهذا وهذا صوت النصر من
العاصمه
[موسيقى]
بالانتصارات الرياضيه نختم واخبار الخامسه
عدو والقاكم في نشره المساء يكون على
الموعد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]